[Musique]
elizabeth ii fait de rongeurs ironique
merci d'être sur le plateau tv 78 pour
ce vip que l'on va entièrement vous
consacrez c'est pas le premier et
j'espère quel honneur bien sûr pas tout
le monde et c'est pas le dernier non
plus j'espère vous êtes là en voisine
vous êtes la taille elles ont peu de
vivre et vous avez une belle actualité
déjà vous avez un métier à multiples
facettes à la base est historienne ce2
s'agit du parfum vous êtes auteur vous
avez écrit donc au moins une dizaine de
vivre à ce jour
cette conseillère pour des grandes
marques de parfumerie
vous avez créé une ligne de bougies
parfumées de parfums d'ambiance
inspirée par versailles inspirée par
versailles top fr alors voilà est-ce que
j'oublie dans votre
je crois que c'est pas mal je suis prof
et lisible carrière ou à l'école si vous
êtes prof voilà ma parmi toutes ces
activités celle qui va nous intéresser
principalement aujourd'hui va concerner
celle d'auteur car vous sortez un beau
livre magnifique qui s'appelle lise la
grande histoire du parfum chez larousse
oui voilà donc vous allez nous parler
avec grand plaisir
elle est donc bien serré weeds est sorti
et les juste magnifique
merci louvre comme un coffret précieux
avec il ya des fac similés à l'intérieur
j'ai jamais très bien compris ce que ça
voulait dire un fac similé
une réplique à l'identique d'un document
d'archivé une photocopie un peu mieux
qu'une fois de la partie quand même
c'est une réplique à l'identique donc à
l'identique évidemment avec
l'authenticité en mon origine en moins
mais sinon oui ce sont de très très
beaux documents qui sont mis au fil des
pages
oui là qui sont là au fil des pages au
mieux ce dont vous parlez absolument est
qui qui aussi donne à prendra conscience
le le trail de l'historien quand on
découvre justement ces documents
authentiques
c'est toujours une émotion un
émerveillement une surprise etc
voilà exactement et là on les repère par
exemple la koala et ben c'est un
histoire des expéditions donc égyptienne
pour aller chercher des plantes à parfum
lentilles comme on disait c'était à la
mire qui arrivait par bateaux jusque
jusqu'au caire pour être offerts dans
les temples d'accord bon et tout à
l'avenant et alors racontez moi
justement ça ça nous prouve bien que
vous avez démarré cette grande histoire
du parfum vraiment là à l'origine la
plus extrême de ce constat sur cette
histoire
oui parce qu'il sort du parfum c'est une
histoire de civilisation est et ce qui
est merveilleux c'est avec le parfum
c'est d'une part celle échange des
cultures c'est l'enrichissement mutuel
ar c'est ces croisements si vous voulez
qu'ils se font au travers des routes du
parfum et puis c'est aussi une histoire
de l'homme tout simplement c'est à dire
ceux ce besoin de se dépasser ce besoin
de se prolonger ce besoin de séduire
aussi ce besoin d'offrir qui est
toujours au coeur du parfum et qu'il
était à l'origine de l'humanité ja et
puis c'est aussi peut être au cours du
temps devenu une association de
multiples savoir-faire prestigieux
absolument là vous en est arrivé
aujourd'hui
tout à fait on sait que le parfum est né
en orient très très très très très
longtemps il ya des millénaires
et puis nous en occident et notamment à
versailles il a joué à la page qui qui
est affichée donc sur les parfums
important on s'est enrichi de tous ses
savoir-faire orientaux donc c'est ça que
je trouve assez merveilleux c'est ce
carrefour de civilisations qui permis
grâce aux parfums et qui se fait
toujours dans le bonheur dans la joie si
vous voulez donc c'est le partage de
vidéos menaçant de connaissances voilà
pour un produit donc joué aujourd'hui
alors racontez moi par exemple
versailles le comment dire l'importance
du parfum à versailles
on en a déjà beaucoup parlé mais mais
c'était là aussi que sont nées les
gantiers parfumeur enfin qu'ils
officiaient elle s'est un peu logiciel
parce que les gantiers parfumeur son nez
principal
sa grâce pardon à grasse et à
montpellier où il y avait des cultures
deux fleuves et culture de fleurs et
puis aussi les troupeaux si vous voulez
qui donnait les po1 et donc comme il
fallait en fleuret cpo pour enlever
cette odeur est ce que c'est moi c'est
instantané
en fait il voulait pour tanner l'epo
depuis le moyen-âge selon une méthode
orientale d'ailleurs les gantiers
utilisaient pas les tanneurs plus
exactement utilisaient des crottes de
chiens dès 2002 cheval des excréments
humains etc
voyez des matières assez olfactivement
désagréable fou mais qu'elles aient des
propriétés chimiques de tanis les
pouilles et en sicile et viérin et
ensuite il fallait enlever cette odeur
âcre qui restait sur les peaux donc
c'est comme ça qu'ils avaient pris
l'habitude de créer des bonnes senteurs
une fois encore c'est orientale accord
est donc c'était un choc des titans ses
actifs et les enlever cette odeur
pestilentielle et ses enseignes par une
bonne odeur et ensuite est arrivé la
mode des gants parfumé catherine 2026
auront valu les seizièmes qu'il n'était
pas parfumé et 4 et des médicis avec son
parfumeur cas l'avs souvenirs avec
quelqu'un d'autre chose ll a demandé à
avoir des gants parfumé exactement à la
mode à la mode c'est l'alsace et des
nombreuses choses qu'on apprend avec un
grand bonheur dans votre magnifique
livre qui est qui reste elle recèle des
tas d'anecdotes inconnus ou connus les
histoires des grands parfums enfin y'a
plein de choses on va pas raconter ça
parce qu'on a pas quatre heures devant
nous en revanche le parfum aujourd'hui
moi je me disais on est un peu à la mode
du fait ou vous même
vos produits de beauté et c est ce qu on
pouvait envisager de faire un parfum soi
même alors oui bien sûr c'est à dire ça
se faisait autrefois on appelait ça la
parfumerie de ménage c'est dire qu'en
fait c'est ce qu'on faisait chez soi
donc ont acheté chez le parfumeur à un
petit kit de parfumerie une sorte de
mini orgue à parfum et on fabriquait
alors c'était pas là c'était pas là la
femme du monde c'était en général ça à
sa gouvernante lui fabriquer donc c'est
essence etc
et puis avait des petits cahiers de
recette on s'était comme le nom indique
une parfumerie ménages s'était quand
même pas d'un cas haute parfumerie
aujourd'hui on nous annonce aujourd'hui
hier il ya des possibilités nuit déjà
yens possibilité de se faire faire des
parfums sur mesure d'accord mais moi
même dans salariés des ateliers qu'ils
le font vous pouvez faire ça à grasse
quand vous allez à grasse par exemple
vous allez chez fragonard chez daxon
molinar et vous avez un collier par
dehors des yvelines fait alors vous dans
les yvelines qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire vous pouvez aller à paris vous
avez un lieu extraordinaire qui vient
degré qui s'appelle the alchemist
atelier ère où vous allez apprendre à
composer votre part heures d'accord donc
les matières moi je peux pas les acheter
alors si vous pouvez toujours vous
procurer des matières mais après si vous
voulez si que le résultat va pas être
terrible
alors que parce que le métier de
parfumeur c'est quand même un peu plus
l'accès à une école de parfumerie c'est
pas pour me c'est quoi la mode
d'aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya des
tendances de fragrances bien sûr alors
on est bien voilà bien sûr l or au nez
il ya il ya deux grandes tendances qui
reste toujours plus ou moins d'actualité
sur le marché de la parfumerie pour les
femmes ce seront les fleurons en le
fameux bouquet floral qui a été mise au
point par marie antoinette au xviiie
siècle qui reste toujours la grande
tendance aujourd'hui seront plutôt un
peu floraux fruité voyez quelque chose
un peu ça s'est un peu de l'air sont un
peu à la mort et puis chez les hommes à
la fougère qu'on appelle aussi
l'aromatique a toujours un gros succès
mais mais on va on va vers des parfums
qui ont plus de tenue aujourd'hui la
demande vraiment une baisse de damien
comment s'est pas retenu c'est que
c'était aussi une demande du marché
d'avoir des marges des jalles parenté
temps comme on disait
et du coup qui donnait plus de légèreté
plus de légèreté opportun donc leur avis
à nouveau d'avoir la matière donc on
vient vers des parfums peu plus textures
et de textures et ça veut dire qui vous
tiennent plus à la peau qui sont plus
sur votre peau et qui reste avec en même
temps toujours ce côté léger aérien en
fin d'avant-midi prise de tête avec le
parfum bon qu'est-ce qu'on peut
envisager un parfum solide
bien sûr ça existait mais ça existait
depuis c'est exister depuis les
égyptiens avec nous alors ça ça bien sûr
ça existe on appelle aujourd'hui encore
des concrète avec voilà voilà donc cédé
community poudrier et puis c'est une
sorte de de pommade qui est parfumé et
qui vous permet d'avoir une gestuelle
assez précise et est ce que ça peu plus
de parfois ans est concret oui ça peut
faire office de parfums mais aussi parce
que ce sont - moins subtile que il ya
plus c'est différent josé sens c'est pas
du tout le même parfumage et s'est
permis en acheter mais concret oui parce
que vous avez des parfumeurs qui le font
chez des grands parfumeurs vous trouvé
vos parfums sous la fin de concrètes
d'accord et du coup ça revient moins
cher jusqu'à pas le joli flacon
magnifique mes yeux mais vous avez un
shérif poudrier et vous avez un génie
contenant c'est pas forcément fait sur
le parfum est un homme politique le jeu
c'est bien et c'est déjà un plaisir de
leur fumée et puis c'est aussi un luxe
donc aujourd'hui on a quand même la
chance d'avoir des parfums avec une
gamme de prix qui est basse et large
c'est vrai bon pour venue au monde du
luxe
vous allez vous avez travaillé récemment
temps conseils pour une marque orientale
justement qui est al jazeera perfumes
car maintenant que moi c'est une
nouvelle aventure ça oui et c'est très
excitant parce que c'est une marque qui
est née il ya vingt ans au qatar à doha
et qui a encore quelques particularités
si vous laissez jeu dont seulement elle
à ce goût pour les belles matières
r comme on en riant on a encore ce goût
du parfumage et parfums qui est intense
qui et voluptueux
mais aussi elle travaille depuis
l'origine avec les plus grands
parfumeurs français d'accord donc a fait
appel au savoir à donner comme dominique
ropion comme sophie labbé qui sont
d'extraordinaires parfumeur actuelle et
qui crée donc tous les parfums
d'algesiras donc elle crée finalement ce
carrefour entre l'orient et l'occident
avec le meilleur des deux parce qu'il en
existe d'autres des parfums d'al jazeera
parce que là on n'est pas aveugle on
voit bien qu 1 à 4 oui mais il en existe
qu il ya énormément c'est une immense
collection à la commande au départ
j'avais parié que vous pouvez découvrir
dans leur boutique qu'ils ont une
boutique parisienne à côté du fouquet's
et là en l'occurrence la nouveauté
l'actualité c'est qu'ils ont sorti
quatre parfums en collaboration avec le
paris saint germain le club de foot
saint germain les yvelines bien sûr
saint germain en laye et le club de
paris qui est né en 1970 qui est ce club
mythique 1 on connaît tous et sur quoi
ce jeu extraordinaire
oui ces joueurs de légende enfin bref
et du coup il ya eu cette très belle
collaboration qui a donné naissance donc
à quatre parfums il fait parfois pour
hommes voilà
non mais non il ya des femmes il ya
aussi une équipe féminine message a
alors blessé
ce sont quatre parfums c'est de la haute
parfumerie et donc on estime qu'il n'y a
pas de parfum pour en août parfum pour
femme ida corr de beaux parfums a donc
ça près de lui à vous de vous de vous
retrouver dans cette
comment dire dans cette danse et parfums
ce que ce que vous préférez portée mais
il n'y a pas de leur travail c'était
soit alors mon travail c'était de les
conseiller sur tout ce qui était le
storytelling donc comment raconter ses
histoires de parfumerie et puis aussi
voilà un peu encadré on
le projet globalement génial ben écoute
elisabeth bravo pour tout ce que vous
faites un grand merci donc je recommande
ce magnifique livre que l'on va pouvoir
voir au salon histoire de livres oui
c'est ça la présente en novembre fin
novembre à 10 heures dédicaces ne
présiderai des signatures dans des
librairies avait un style est ailleurs
il ya aussi voilà on peut vous
rencontrez on peut discuter
oui et et voilà c'était un magnifique
voyage a pu mais que vous nous offrez là
c'est gentil merci à bientôt
à très bientôt dépêchez-vous trop de
jeunes choristes en cours est en cours
abobo est formidable mais verts
elizabeth au revoir au revoir
[Musique]